the acquisition of turbonomic a big
milestone for the ibm cloud for
financial services
and the ibm cloud podcast all on this
episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
first up this week i am thrilled to
announce that ibm has completed the
acquisition of turbonomic
an application resource management and
network performance management software
provider
turbonomic offers complete full stack
visibility of applications
optimizing performance and the cost of
running the application
this is the latest step in ibm's goal of
creating a one-stop shop for ai-powered
automation capabilities
it complements ibm's recent acquisition
of instanta and the launch of ibm cloud
pack for watson ai ops
together these capabilities will be a
powerful application-centric ai ops
solution for organizations that are
working to meet the demands of their
customers
to learn more about ai powered
automation and why ibm is the right
vendor for you
check out the blog linked in the
description of this video
next up i want to talk about an exciting
milestone for the ibm cloud for
financial services
which is a solution designed to help
banks host mission-critical workloads
while adhering to security and
compliance regulations
nearly one year after we introduced you
to the world's first financial services
ready cloud
we're pleased to announce that the
platform is now backed by more than 100
ecosystem
partners this rapidly growing ecosystem
of partners can help financial
institutions
integrate offerings from third-party
providers modernize legacy applications
and speed the path to market ultimately
our goal is to accelerate cloud adoption
in the financial services industry
by offering a cloud with built-in
security and regulatory framework
that helps partners and their customers
accelerate their journeys to cloud
to learn more about the partner
ecosystem check out the link below
to wrap things up today i want to
quickly shine a light on the ibm cloud
podcast
hosted by dan bettinger the podcast
explores capabilities
methods and discoveries to help you work
better with cloud
the latest episode features doug davis
an offering manager for ibm cloud code
engine
and dan and doug discuss how code engine
allows developers to get out of the
infrastructure business
and spend more time coding give it a
listen and learn how to run your
container
application code or batch job on a fully
managed container runtime
this is the third episode of the ibm
cloud podcast and there are many more to
come
so hit the link below to listen and
subscribe
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you